okay guys in this problem a dam holding
back 30 acre feet of water is opened and
releases its water through a rectangular
concrete channel the channel is 5T wide
and 4T tall it has a uniform slope of
0.1% the concrete channel has a
roughness of
0.013 the flow is kept steady such that
the depth of water in the channel does
not exceed half of its height how long
will the dam take to empty in hours so
the first thing we're going to do is go
to our reference manual and there we can
find our equation for Manning's equation
for steady uniform flow since that's a
really what this
problem's looking at for us to
use so that's going to be 1.4 9 over n *
a Time the hydraulic radius to the 2/3
time slope to the
1/2 and if you want to solve for just
velocity we can take area out of both
sides of
this and leave us with
just these
terms now if you're having trouble
remembering what hydraulic radius is
it's area
over wetted perimeter if you're having
trouble visualizing wetted perimeter
it's the area of water that comes in
contact or the length of water that
comes in contact with the channel
so in this
case PW for a rectangular channel is
going to be W +
2H and in this problem since it's all
over
2/3 that's going to be both of those as
well but let's start with the very first
thing we need for now which is going to
be the total volume of
water in the
dam
so
30 acre
feet times
fet
squared per
acre um acre feet is a volume it's the
acreage is the square footage and then
the depth is the foot so multiplying by
the conversion which you can either have
memorized or pull out of the
equation by uh the reference manual
gives you
800 cubic
feet and now that we know the
total volume we can put that aside for a
bit and calculate
the
velocity coming out of
the coming out of the dam into the
channel
so we're going to say 1.49 over
0.013
times we're going to split up the r here
into its constituents to make it easier
to solve if you want to visualize it as
we go you don't have to do it this way
but the area of the dam in this case
is 5 ft which was the width and it was
noted that the flow is kept such that
the depth is always going to be half the
height of the 4ot tall Dam so it's going
to be 2
feet and that's going to be
over the wed perimeter here so
5 ft + 2 *
2T and all of that in this case is to
the
23 and then finally we're going to have
our slope which said it's 0.1 so that's
going to be 0.0
Z1 when it's not expressed as a
percent and and that's going to be to
the
1/2 so if you solve for each of these
parts um sometimes I do that in my
calculator if I'm worried I'm going to
make a typo with a bigger number or a
bigger set of numbers it takes more time
so it's up to you to decide if you have
the time available but it's also a good
check as you go so I broke up those into
these
they both
equal
3.89 feet per
second
and that brings us to step
three we're trying to
[Music]
find the total flow rate so we could
have just done it right I guess with the
uh other equation as
well now going to be qal VA
so
3.89 per second
time 5T time 2 feet because that's the
area in the channel and that's going to
give us 38.888421100000
to find time so we have our total
volume and we have our
flow if we solve that'll give us a Time
component so in this case we're going to
do
800 ft cubed
over 38.888421100000
[Music]
this is going to give
us
seconds
um and just
calculating
for more unit conversions
now we can solve
or in
hours you could also again just do one
over 3600 for a direct
comparison
um I just like to write these out since
this is meant to teach you and that's
going to give you about
9.3 hours which is our third answer over
here